hi my name is Peggy Johnson and I'm
executive vice president for global
market development welcome and the
question i'm answering today is where do
I see that in America in 2050 and I see
that from two perspectives first I think
women will play a greater role in the
evolution of technology we have a huge
demand for more scientists engineers and
women today when we make up about to a
percent of our engineering so I think
will be very much involved in that
evolution and what does that evolution
look like I think it will be amazing and
we'll be living in a very connected
world will be delivering education
through our wireless devices to people
at virtually in all corners of the world
corners of Latin America we will be
monitoring our blood pressure over our
devices and the home itself were
probably very very different maybe more
of a wearable device than something that
we live in trains so that's what I see
for the future in 2050 mMmmm